hey everybody uh
should be
should be good to go right I think uh
looks like everything's active
all right
so
let's see here uh welcome to the January
live stream
um we're gonna
foreign
we're gonna have some fun today I think
all right so
anyway anyone who hasn't seen like my
social media posts over the last uh week
or so uh what we're gonna be doing today
is we are going to be
um we're gonna be testing out chat GPT
and if you're unfamiliar this is a AI
bot that's been very popular in the last
couple of months
um I've been playing with it a little
bit already for things
but uh get sort of getting a feel for it
and I thought what the heck let's let's
just do
let's let's do a live stream
all right so
that being said we're gonna do a screen
share
Infinity all right and so
chat GPT should be up on the screen
um all right
and so we're going to start asking this
questions we've got the chat open on a
separate screen this time so I can see
it at all times while we're playing
around with the screen the screen share
um
and so yeah we're gonna we're gonna have
some fun uh looks like I think we
already have some questions very active
chat right now
um
[Music]
so yeah so it says uh longwin
m longwin
social media Post Yeah I posted it to
the community tab too but uh not
everyone gets notifications for the
community tab
um
I know the way the the notification
system works
you can only get like three a day or
something
um and so if you only focus on normal
videos then like that's what you're
going to be notified about if you focus
on live streams or you know if you don't
really use the community tabs
um it's not gonna notify you about
Community tab posts
foreign
but it's just it's how it works
all right
uh we've got some questions here let's
see
I saw a good one someone asked to ask
that to do math I think
uh well let's see here here's one um
when an electron is is okay when an
electron is an atom is in superposition
what does it mean
does that mean it's in multiple orbits
I'm going to ask it quantum mechanics
questions I'm going to start off strong
all right
let's see here I'm gonna start a new
chat
um
we could probably start it off simple
and just say something like
what is a Quantum superposition
see what happens
oh boy it's going to be involved
I want to know how many times this says
quantum mechanics
all right
oh wow it's going to give me an essay
for whatever reason uh when I did this
before it it uh only gave me like one
sentence answers it was very short
let's see all right in quantum mechanics
a Quantum superposition is a fundamental
principle that describes the behavior of
a Quantum system that can exist in
multiple States simultaneously well kind
of
[Music]
um
uh it certainly exists in multiple
stationary States but the superposition
itself is also a state so
um
there's some ambiguity there
uh let's see this is a consequence of
the fact that the state of a Quantum
system is described by a wave function
sure
which can be a complex valued function
that encodes the probabilities of
various outcomes when the system is
measured all right so I think this is
getting at what uh
Brian was asking right where
the question is
um
is it really in multiple States or is it
just
in
uh is it just a matter of like it drops
into one when we measure it or or
whatever
um
and this is something I've done a video
on before but
uh essentially we don't know uh and
hopefully this gets into it a little
later but we we don't actually know for
sure
foreign
there's there there are some issues I
mean regardless it's we it's weird
regardless
um I should say counterintuitive it's
counter-intuitive
regardless of what the truth ends up
being but
um so far so good
uh when a Quantum system is in a
superposition it means that it is in a
combination of two or more States at the
same time it should really be stationary
States I'll make sure I correct it here
in a minute
uh for example consider an electron it
can be either a two two energy states
um which is here n equals one two three
are stationary States
um if the electron is in a superposition
of these two states
uh with a certain probability of being
in each state this is not bad actually
um
this is very different from the
classical world where a system can only
be in one state at a time
so we're gonna do this not a bad answer
however
a superposition
is itself a state
it is a combination
specifically a linear combination
of
stationary States
stationary States
are States
that can be measured
foreign
[Music]
freaks out about
what's going on with uh this whole
system right and how this actually works
while this is giving me a follow-up
answer
um basically
foreign
this is essentially like Googling
something now this doesn't have access
to the internet yet which I think is for
the best the Internet is just full of
misinformation but
um this does have access to a lot of
information that it was used that was
used to train this thing
um and so this is sort of I think it's
meant um I don't know if they've
actually said this but I think this is
meant to be sort of a Next Level Google
Search right where like when you're
trying to search something on Google and
you type in a question like this just a
conversational question you're probably
not going to get the best results
uh and in order to get the best results
out of something like Google or
um you know one of those other search
engines you you need
you need to like
essentially uh structure your input to
get out the right output right you need
to kind of know how the search engine
works and I think the goal behind
something like this is is to make a
search for information more
conversational
so you're you're just talking to a
person and it it makes it more I guess
accessible
to more it makes it accessible to more
people
um because if you're at least familiar
on how to converse with a person you can
converse with the search engine this is
a very advanced search engine uh but
although it does get things wrong
because it then has to take the
information that it's looking up in its
databases and
kind of compile it into an answer like a
person would speak
uh and that doesn't always it doesn't
always work out
the way
that that that we wanted to
um all right so
I've officially corrected it and it says
ah yes you're correct
uh in quantum mechanics a superposition
is indeed a state in the quantum system
It's a combination of two or more
stationary states that are states that
correspond to energy eigenvalues of the
system so now we're take it has taken
this up
um sort of an educational level here
instead of giving a generic answer that
you might want to read if you don't know
anything about quantum mechanics now it
is based on my correction it has
essentially judged what my knowledge
level is and it has changed Its Behavior
in response which is
pretty wicked if you ask me
um
uh let's see let's see it is a
combination of two energy stationary
States so stationary state is
essentially just something that can
actually be measured right it's it's a
stationary State also known as an
eigenstate which I'll hopefully do a
video about eventually but
um basically there's a a set of values
that a measurement can take on and those
values
are called the eigenvalues and uh each
stationary State corresponds to an
eigenvalue
um now each Quantum State could
potentially be a combination of those
eigenstates
uh although that superposition as we
call it is not measurable
uh so as I say quantum superposition can
be measured mathematically as a linear
combination see and this is sort of what
it gathered for me I said linear
combination and it's like ah math terms
okay
um and so you can see here it's giving
the structure of
a linear combination which is basically
just linear algebra
um nothing too crazy since I hope that
this helps to clarify the concept of
quantum superposition let me know if you
have any more questions
all right
um
got some good oh someone's asking about
video title suggestions uh yeah so this
is a over here on the left um says video
title suggestions this is one of the
first things I tried playing around with
with
um by the way I've never actually used
any of its title suggestions
uh just so you know
um they're not great
they're middlest
is is a word I like to use
uh they are
they're okay you know they might be a
decent like
back up if mine don't actually work out
the ones I come up with myself
um
they'll look like baby for me I think uh
not that I haven't done clickbaity
titles but there's there's a line you
know you don't want to cross it and some
of these kind of cross it a bit
um but something that that to keep in
mind is this this
AI system does not like
it doesn't have
a knowledge of like
it doesn't have like experience with
like
sociology with people right and and what
people are going how people are going to
respond to a title right it's just
grabbing information that it is aware of
other video titles that happen to be on
YouTube and kind of like piecing
together that format with the
information that I've given it about the
video
um
at some point I might try putting in
like a cold open from one of my videos
and see what happens
um but it's just something I'm
experimenting with and you know it might
be something that happens eventually
you know that we eventually you know it
eventually gets better at because it
develops the patterns it's never going
to have experience like a person has
experience with other people but
um it it might find a way
to figure it out using its own structure
uh in a way that we won't anticipate
which is
cool but like at the moment it's it's
still a work in progress you know and
all these interactions that we do with
it um are improving it which is cool so
they're basically getting like you know
free AI training out of out of making
this Public Public Access
um Michaela says I tried feeding it
homework questions on uh semiconductor
physics it did a decent job giving a
starting point for solving the problems
but it then cut off in the middle of the
solution
uh yeah I mean it's it's it's it's it's
uh
ability is limited
um let's see
okay so we got a math question uh ask it
to do the integral of the square root of
x squared minus one all right let's see
let's let's give it a math question
can you solve
the integral
of
the square root
of x
squared minus 1.
see what happens the integral of the
square root of x squared minus 1 cannot
be expressed in terms of Elementary
functions however it can be expressed in
terms of inverse the inverse tangent
function also known as the arctan
oh look at this go
uh the indefinite integral of the square
root
okay okay okay it's going it's going
wow look at this thing go
pulling out the negative sign for some
reason
it got stuck
man it it had a hard time with that
um I'm gonna go out on a limb and assume
this is not solvable I don't know this
particular
integral offhand
because usually the arctan is one over
this right
it got stuck
I mean it might be the arcotan if it's
upside down that might work out
um anyway it didn't do it right so again
like it's not exactly sure
what it's doing I guess
um it kind of like made the integrand
more complicated and then re-simplified
it and sort of got back to uh its
original form
which
um
limits of integration right so it's it's
basically saying oh well you can solve
it with uh
limits because then you can do it
numerically but
um doesn't really
doesn't really know what it's doing
yet anyway
but I for one welcome our AI overlords
just a guy like to put that on the
record
uh see
as I dissolve P versus NP
um you know it might actually be aware
of this
the P versus NP problem is a famous
unsolved problem in computer science
that asks whether every problem that can
be efficiently verified by a computer
known as an NP problem can be
efficiently solved by computer
no it's a p problem
or specifically
despite much effort remains unsolved
it's actually given a pretty decent
answer
um it's a little jargony but uh
despite much effort it's unsolved
there are many different approaches to
the P versus NP problem and researchers
continue to work on trying to find a
solution however the problem is still
not well understood and it is not clear
when or if a solution will be found
right so
the P versus NP problem I don't know a
lot about this but
basically
um
there are
problems that I think was it a Matt
Parker video that I saw on this maybe
um but basically
mathematically speaking they're a set of
they're you know there's the whole big
set of problems
um and some of them can be solved by a
computer and some of them can't
uh and we're not exactly sure how big
the bubble is
that
that uh of problems that can be solved
by a computer
um
but
it says can be verified by a computer as
the NP problem
um
and so the question is right so like
just because a computer can sort of
recognize that you know the problem it
doesn't mean it can solve it but
um if a mathematician has ever manages
to prove P versus NP what that means is
the P equals NP I should say
um is that the the problems the the
bubble that includes the problems
um is the same but uh this is sort of
one of those ongoing math problems
uh and it recognized that we don't
actually have a solution so
oh that's a good one
what is the answer
to life
the universe
I can't type
and everything
foreign
debate and speculation okay it appears
that it is not aware of oh oh here it
comes here comes
in the science fiction comedy
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy Douglas
Adams famously
suggested that the answer is 42. uh
however this is a joke and not a serious
answer to the question well that's
boring
um but I mean at least it's aware it's
aware that it is science fiction
um but it says in reality the answer to
the ultimate question of life the
universe and everything May beyond
beyond our current understanding and
ability to comprehend which
sure
uh it is possible that we will never
fully understand the ultimate nature of
the universe and our place within it
uh it's depressing but factual
um however this does not stop people
from continuing to seek answers right
because
maybe we can
might just take us some time
all right
foreign
ER alert says P equals NP is about
whether or not whether problems that can
be verified in polynomial time can also
be solved in polynomial time
for example you can easily check and
integer prime factorization but finding
one can be hard
right so enter integer prime
factorization
um is something that's a really big
thing in cryptography
um
and uh if we ever find uh this is why P
equals NP or P versus NP is a big deal
is because
um
all of this the the coding that we use
to keep
uh information secure on the internet
what if it would essentially be not
secure anymore if that was the if that
was uh if that were possible
um so uh I suppose it's a good thing
that we haven't solved it yet
uh can you list all the planets in the
solar system seeing how it does with
Pluto oh you're playing with fire now
can you list all the planets
in the solar system
foreign
there are eight planets in the solar
system yeah there are
in addition to these planets there are
also many dwarf planets in the solar
system including Pluto Ceres and Eris
among others the solar system also
includes many other celestial bodies
such as comets asteroids and moons
there are more than 200 moons in the
solar system the largest of which is
Ganymede a moon of Jupiter
um yeah the Jupiter's moons are
planet-sized the terrestrial planet size
one of them is actually is it bigger
than Mars I can't remember if Ganymede
is bigger than Mars I think it is
um but there it is right and this is
this is factual whether you like it or
not this is
this is the situation right we've
reclassified Planets versus dwarf
planets
uh Pluto the reason Pluto isn't a planet
anymore is
I mean there's lots of reasons but
basically the new criteria for
uh planets is that they must clear out
they must you know significantly which
is a bit subjective but they must
significantly clear out their orbit
which essentially means they must clear
out their orbits of
um comparably sized objects and so even
though say for example Earth's orbit
isn't completely clear there's asteroid
fields and stuff that we pass through
which cause you know media you know very
regular meteor showers as the Earth
orbits the Sun
um but those are little tiny rocks
they're not planet-sized objects whereas
Pluto is in the middle of a belt of
comets
that um you know some are small but uh
there are several others that are
pluto-ish sized Pluto just happens to be
the biggest one
um and so Pluto's just a really really
big comet
essentially
uh but because it's big it's so big that
the mass the you know its gravity has
spherized it it's turned it into a
sphere or at least really close to a
sphere it smoothed out its shape it's
not a lumpy potato like a lot of these
objects
uh
I'm perfectly comfortable with that
classification and giving that some you
know special treatment
and so uh you know lumpy things like
asteroids and small comets and stuff are
definitely I can see the need for having
a separate category for the larger
objects that end up being spheres even
if they don't clear out their orbits and
so dwarf planet sounds fine to me
um I didn't have any I never had any
objections to that
um but you know another reason we we had
to go through a classification like this
is because
we needed to make sure that
we didn't want this the list of planets
in the solar system to be you know 100
objects long that's it's not useful
um you need something not only to to
communicate effectively what you're
talking about but also like
educationally
you know when you're trying to teach
kids what the planets in the solar
system are you need that list to be
small you can't have it be a hundred
long and people aren't going to remember
those names it's just not
it's not going to happen so there's some
you know practicality here
uh let's see what is the key to Fusion
Energy
laughs
Fusion Energy has the potential to
provide a virtually Limitless
virtually sure
and clean source of electricity the
process of fusion occurs when the nuclei
of two light atoms
light as in like lightweight lightweight
atoms such as hydrogen combined to form
a heavier atom
uh
releasing a large amount of energy in
the process this process is similar to
uh the one that powers the Sun and other
stars the key to achieving practical
Fusion Energy is to find a way to
initiate and sustain a controlled fusion
reaction which is definitely the problem
um this requires
this requires creating
where's where's my spot an extremely
high temperatures and pressures needed
uh to force the atomic nuclei there we
go
I was about to correct it the atomic
nuclei diffused together as well as
finding a way to contain the hot ionized
plasma that is produced during the
reaction
right so
um
this is this is not bad uh an inertial
confinement magnetic confinement plasma
Focus right there's a lot of different
ways we're trying to do it
um magnetic confinement probably has the
most
practicality
um in my opinion
uh but stability is still a problem
and so
um I'm glad that it mentioned nuclei I
was about to correct it on that but
uh yeah so
extremely high temperatures and
pressures is an understatement right so
we've got hydrogen Fusion happening
inside the Sun but the sun is large
enough that it's able to take advantage
of quantum tunneling whereas a small
reactor sitting on the Earth's surface
can't and so the fugitive reactors on
the earth have to be much much hotter
than the core of the Sun to work
uh because there just aren't enough
particles
the statistics don't work in our favor
for Quantum tunneling and so we have to
actually push the nuclei together
which is a huge obstacle right I mean
the the sun's core alone is already 15
million Kelvin
uh and and so in a in a Earth surface
reactor we're easily talking 150 million
like 10 times the amount
it's very hot very high pressures it is
not surprising that we're having a hard
time stabilizing the reaction it's just
not that surprising
this is a hard problem
and so just something to to keep in mind
uh say Constellation Pegasus said how
about a video on Virtual photons in in
QED
uh
yeah I mean I could
all right so here's the thing
I've only ever done one video on Quantum
field Theory and QED is quantum
electrodynamics it is a Quantum field
Theory
uh I've only done one video
on Quantum field Theory because that's
about the extent that I understand it I
actually had
I had a a researcher
I I gave I gave a topic to a researcher
that is uh more skilled in this than I
am hoping that I could you know get an
outline back and and and you know with
all the information and sources and
everything and it's still just it's a
lot
and I've been trying to teach Myself by
reading a Quantum field Theory Book I
don't know if it's
uh yeah it's down here
um
on the Shelf but uh
it's
it's a very different
the notation is is getting me a little
bit the mathematical notation so
um
it might be a while I need to kind of I
need to feel confident about my
understanding in it before I can do it
uh QED specifically isn't too bad
but I feel like I want to
to add something
to the conversation if I just do a
generic video on QED it I'm not going to
be saying anything that other people
haven't said uh and I wanna I wanna add
something to you know
the the Zeitgeist
of of YouTube videos on it
um all right let's see see what we got
it gives the typical virtual particle
explanation if you ask it about Hawking
radiation but it acknowledges that
that's just an intuitive explanation
that's not fundamentally correct
I suppose we could ask about it
um
but yeah let's see how it does with
Quantum field Theory this is what we're
here for right
um
what are virtual particles
in quantum mechanics well it's not
really in quantum mechanics virtual
particles are particles that can be that
can temporarily exist in a vacuum or
empty space these particles are not
observed directly and do not have a
definite existence like real particles
do okay
uh vague but true uh instead they are
thought to borrow energy from the vacuum
and then return it after a short period
Well it kind of
um ritual particles are a consequence of
the uncertainty principle I would not
say that
uh which states that it is impossible to
know the exact no
no they're not
this means that according to the
uncertainty principle particles can
borrow energy from the vacuum in order
to exist temporarily as long as they
return the energy within a certain time
frame
uh okay it's starting to combine things
together that shouldn't be combined
[Music]
um
let's see
virtual particles
are more
from Quantum field Theory then from
quantum mechanics
all right
they began as a mathematical tool
to help solve
Quantum field Theory problems
uh yeah yeah it is it is very friendly
isn't it
um I like I like its manners it's it's
got good manners which I think is
probably part of the design
uh they began his mathematical tool
they'll solve problems
they're real physical
existence is debatable
but
the uncertainty principle
doesn't actually
have anything to do with them
let's see what happens
uh thanks for the correction and Quantum
field Theory virtual particles yes yes
and sort of
foreign
structuring its question given my new
information which sounds a little better
changing my figures of speech into its
own figures of speech which is
impressive
uh they're thought to play a role in
many phenomenon going on field Theory
including the electromagnetic force the
strong and weak nuclear forces and the
Higgs mechanism okay it's doing better
it's doing better
laughs
um
let's see
what would the universe look like yeah
let's go with that one what would the
universe
look like and you are getting you're all
getting a uh a glimpse into how me
writing videos goes where it's all the
typos
um what would the universe look like
from the perspective
of a photon
see if we can do this
oh and then we got it good we got to get
another math question here
foreign
from the perspective of a folk town the
universe would appear very different
from how we see it sure
photons are particles of light that
always travel at the speed of light so
they do not experience the passage of
time in the same way that we do or they
don't experience at all
uh from their perspective of a photon
the universe would be vest empty space
with no matter or energy present
what
the photon would travel in a straight
line through this empty space never
experiencing any force or interaction of
other with other particles
uh
yeah I think we gave it a trick question
and it's having a hard time
it's just a thought experiment it's not
possible for a photon or any particle to
have a subjective perspective in the
same way sure yeah that's fine nice
little uh Nuance at the end there but
this is
this is a way off
actually
if photons don't
experience the passage of time
because they travel at the speed of
light
let's not say that
uh
then there's nothing to experience
um
um there's nothing to experience this is
true
for anything
traveling at the speed of light
parentheses
which is really
just the maximum speed of causality
foreign
I'm sorry for the trick question
okay
if it's going to be polite to me I'm
going to be polite back
the concept of time is closely tied to
the concept of causality which is the
idea that events in the universe are
connected by cause and effect
relationships yes at the speed of light
causality breaks down and it becomes
impossible to distinguish between past
present and future there we go
uh this is because the speed of light is
the maximum speed at which information
can be transmitted and if something were
to travel at the speed of light it would
take an infinite amount of time for its
position to change according to our
observations
uh well
um
any changes or events
not bad
not bad
uh there was a
Science question there was a math
question
someone really wanted me to to give this
math so let's see if I can find it again
it's citing the Wikipedia page on
Virtual particles oh boy
they're actually okay so
Wikipedia is
problematic
um
there are there are a few physics pages
in particular that need some updating
and
um
none of us physicists can actually
update them because we make changes and
the changes are reverted within 24 hours
uh
so while they say that uh you know
anyone can edit Wikipedia it's not
actually true
um
it's technically true but not
practically true
uh so just because you're reading a
Wikipedia it does not necessarily make
it accurate
I saw one in here
um someone said I was so frustrated with
chat GPT because I was trying to I was
trying
to help me with code and giving me
things that just don't work at all uh
but it was sure it could uh yeah I mean
it is nothing if not confident
um
but I think like I was saying at the
beginning of this whole thing I think
that
if you know the goal is to you know
provide
answers to people's questions
um if it's not confident most people are
not going to take it seriously you know
they're not going to take the answers
seriously right com people respond to
confidence
and you know whether or not that should
be the case is irrelevant it just is
people respond to confidence
um
but but yeah so like try not to worry
too much about this thing I mean this
this software certainly changes
its existence changes a lot of the ways
that we do things
uh particularly in education
um
but I don't think it's anything to be
afraid of or mad about I think it's just
something we have to adapt to you know
the world changes it's just
how it goes and I mean I don't like it
you know most of us would like the world
to just stay the same all the time
um
most of us
but I
it does change and this is like a
reality that we have to live with you
know um something I always try to remind
myself I try to say to myself is uh
adapt or atrophy
um
it's kind of a a play on the like
publisher Parish thing in Academia but
applied to like the whole world if you
don't you know changes happen and
there's no way to stop them and there's
no going back to when blank you know
whatever fill in the blank
um you can't go back and so you just
kind of have to adapt to the new world
and if you don't you're going to be left
behind unfortunately
um now
changes in the past have always been a
bit more uh a bit slower
than they have been lately uh and that
that is making it difficult to for
people to adapt which I understand
but um we're gonna have to eventually
adapt to it
I mean I can't find it now
the feed is 600 600 viewers that's a lot
no wonder I can't find this
um
oh here we go let's just start with a
simple one
what is one plus one while I'm looking
is equal to two this is the basic
principle of arithmetic
did it just get sassy
uh which is the branch of mathematics
that deals with the addition subtraction
the division of numbers
wow it is given a detailed answer for
this
can you prove
one plus one equals two
testing its limits
oh I like this one
uh it's considered to be self-evident it
does not require a formal proof this is
because the concept of addition is
defined as combining two or more
quantities to find their sum okay so it
is not aware of number Theory
isn't there a proof in number Theory
foreign
it is possible to provide a formal proof
for the statement one plus one equals
two
one way to do this is to use a concept
of induction which is Method oh here we
go that's cool
huh
okay
I don't know if I can specifically fact
check this but um
interesting okay so it is aware of
number Theory so I think
um
every once in a while it seems to like
settle back into
[Music]
uh thinking that I'm a non-scientist and
it just kind of gives me general answers
and I have to like coax it into you know
I have to remind it that I am a
physicist
um
uh someone in the chat was asking what I
have a degree in and it's it's physics
um although it doesn't really tell you
much physics is pretty broad uh my
specialization my research was on white
dwarf stars
uh specifically their internal structure
and stuff which I'm hoping to do a video
about this year
uh it's on it's on the list for 2023.
um
uh
all right there's another question let's
let's go something a little easier
if you travel
one mile
I lost it but if you travel one mile
south
one mile East I'm gonna at least
paraphrase
and then one mile North
and your
at your original location
where are you
oh it knows it knows
you're at the North Pole
the North Pole is a point on the Earth's
surface that is located at the
northernmost end of the Earth's axis of
rotation
uh it is the point where all lines of
longitude converge and it is the only
place on Earth's surface where a person
can travel in a straight line in any
direction and end up at the same point
ah I see what it's saying you all end up
at the South Pole it's just not
clarifying right okay
um
although that's not true
though is it
uh because you can you can stand on any
point on a sphere and walk in any
direction in a straight line and end up
at the same point
foreign
t
y it is the only place on Earth's
surface where a person can travel in a
straight line in any direction and end
up at the South Pole
foreign
it's just going to correct it okay
so moving on what other questions we got
here
foreign
nope it didn't fix its answer I don't
know okay
let's see
I mean you got to give it to it no one
at least the North Pole
I mean that's impressive
I can show its code window how do I do
that
um
I could I could ask it to write some
code though that could be fun
foreign
let's keep it simple
write code in Python that will add two
input numbers together
oh
input sure sure
okay
yeah I mean it appears to be
I appreciate that it assumed that uh
unless stated otherwise that the number
should be floating Point numbers that's
a good that's a good way to go
wow
I mean this is going to save this is
going to save programmers so much time
it's got to
and like obviously it's not going to get
everything right you're gonna have to
you know
debug it sometimes especially if the
code is really long but uh this is not
bad this is not bad and it's even asking
it's even asking for numbers I I
wouldn't have bothered if I was writing
the code
um
because I would just be writing the code
for me and it wouldn't really matter but
like yeah
I like it
um
this is
because I think when you when you input
when you input it's just a string
probably right
says uh lots of debugging
um it does give you a good start though
yeah I mean the most annoying part of
writing code for anything is the start
right
just just getting it going
you know you got all the like you know
Header information sometimes it's just
oh no I forgot to include this package
and uh yeah so like getting a good start
but then you can tweak it I mean it's
going to give you error messages when
you try to run it maybe
um depending on how complex it is
uh
so I mean this is
this is this is not bad
I mean should we try it
uh uh what's it called right
let's try the code
run module
oh okay it's gonna yell at me
okay
enter a number
uh let's see
325.67 oh
I had an unlock an accident
enter another number
five
that's beautiful
that's fun that's fun
I might actually try this the next time
I need to write something really simple
and I'm just like done
I'm just emotionally done making
animations for a video
uh this usually happens near the end of
the process I'm just so frustrated
um but it's that
cool
um totally functional code I am
impressed
chat GPT can run the code
all right I got I Gotta See
I'm sorry but I am unable to execute the
code however you can run the code
yourself in a python interpreter
and then it goes ahead and explains it
will not run the code for you
I think that's probably for the best
it can write python code for blender
interesting
because you know honestly like
I'm kind of familiar with blender like I
I know
I've used it in a video or two not
nothing crazy but the problem is that
it's
it's made for artists
for you know you you want to like make
you know go through the donut tutorial
but like then you're just like kind of
brushing things and like adjusting
colors and stuff with a brush and
you know warping objects and extruding
them and it
it's not exactly how I my brain works
I'm not really
set up for that I have a much easier
time just coding in V python
it's the visual visual python package
uh and
and the newest version of V python
actually has a way for you to export
frames and then you can just I can just
import the frames in After Effects and
it makes an animation form it makes it
an animation for me
um and and so I've been trying I've been
doing that lately when when After
Effects kind of fails me but
um I mean blender would make it prettier
and so if I could make code for blender
that would be cool
that maybe I can actually include more
you know more blender stuff
let's see
can you well let's move on though can
you define a nonagon
foreign
polygon with nine sides and nine angles
it is a two-dimensional shape that is
closed and has straight sides I mean
this makes sense I've used the word uh
no knuckle
um you know where you've got like
you know double and triple there's like
uh a no knuckle is is nine
oh
sorry about that I have an alarm on my
computer that tells me to get up and
walk around every hour
um
so a nonagon having nine sides totally
tracks with me
um
and there also known as any agons
and they belong to a family of shapes
called n-gons where the N is the number
of sides
um
I remember recently like in the last
month or so Michael Stevens from Vsauce
put out a short
um and a tick tock and a Instagram reel
but uh put out something about
um really big
really big numbers of sides of things
almost looked like a circle but it had
like a thousand or ten thousand or a
hundred thousand sides
I can't remember what the names of them
are but uh
the point to the video
um well you know what go watch it it's
it's a nice little short
Michael's been really enjoying his
shorts making
Auto contacts that sounds so bad uh
Michael's been really enjoying making
short short content
um and it's been a blast so
he's been making good stuff
um
uh I have not tried mannum yet I
probably won't
um it seems just a bit a bit too much
when V python exists
um
I think what what
made me nervous about it was
that like if you there's it's a really
complicated install and if you install
it incorrectly
it like can break your computer and I
just can't really afford to have my
computer turn into a brick
um
uh let's see
yeah I mean you don't have to ask it
nicely but I would prefer to you know
foreign
let's get to some more science questions
here though
we all know you want to be sciency but
one thing it does well is write poems
maybe I can have it write a science poem
um can you write a poem
about
Einstein's general relativity
I'm going to
uh Einstein's theory of general
relativity explains the fabric of the
universe to me it tells us gravity works
you see
curving space and time so strange and
dreamy
Mass has been the fabric of the cosmos
like a bowling ball on a mattress it
goes
the planets orbit around the sun
following paths that have been won
Einstein's theory has been proved right
by experiments and tests that take
flight it revolutionized our
understanding of the cosmos and its
expanding
that's really good
I'm gonna thumbs that one right up oh no
I'll go back and do it later
um wow all right
that is that is impressive
wow
this is a loving my boxers as well
uh let's see
I can code in every language I've tried
got lots of coders in the comments here
I was hoping for astrophysics questions
well let me try it let me try one
what exactly is a black hole
let's give it a doozy
a black hole is a region of space where
the gravitational pull is so strong that
nothing and not even light can escape
black holes are formed when a massive
star collapses at the end of its life
creating a singularity
or a point of infinite density and zero
volume where the laws of physics as we
know them break down
there are several types of black holes
including Stellar black holes which are
formed from the collapse of a star
supermassive black holes which are much
larger and are thought to exist at the
center of most galaxies and intermediate
Mass black holes which are larger than
those but smaller than these
uh black holes are some of the most
mysterious fascinating objects in the
universe
have we found any
intermediate Mass
black holes
that are between one and a hundred
thousand solar masses
I thought to be the missing link between
Stellar mass and super massive black
holes however they are much harder to
detect
uh because they do not produce
they do not produce as much radiation as
their gravitationally uh and their
gravitational influence is weaker
well that's not true
despite this there is evidence for the
Existence
um in a number of different environments
so I'm gonna guess it if we have
detected them it's not aware of any
foreign
I'm not going to correct it on the
gravitational influence thing because
the gravitational tidal forces are
weaker
but I mean more mass means more
gravitational influence so it
it's it's having a some some nuanced
issues here
uh what happens to time inside a black
hole
foreign
Fabric in the vicinity the gravity is so
strong that it warps and bends
as you get closer the gravitational
field time slows down even more sure
sure
although this is just an illusion
essentially yeah
inside the Event Horizon the
gravitational field becomes so strong
that time and space completely are
completely unrecognizable
uh
that's a bit of hyperbolization but sure
um all right so let's talk about this
uh does time slow down as you approach
the black hole I mean there's definitely
a difference in the passage of time
between someone who is there and someone
who is far away that is not an illusion
that's just reality that's the reality
of time
um but it only says that time stopping
is an illusion and I think this just
this is another one of those like
English language things where it's kinda
right
um
but might give you the impression that
the time slowing down is an illusion
which it isn't
um time definitely stops
at the Event Horizon for a distant
Observer it just doesn't stop for the
in-falling Observer
uh and so that's just something to keep
in mind that one of the things that
black holes do is they
different things happen
depending on who's observing it which is
just it's wild it's wild
um I was hoping it would say something
about the inside of the black hole in
time switching places with space
although it kind of just generalizes it
as
time and space being unrecognizable
which I think I mean it's accurate vague
but accurate
so that's not that's not too bad
foreign
asked about wormholes can could a black
hole be an entrance to a wormhole let's
ask that
uh could be an entrance to Wormhole
which is a hypothetical Passage through
space and time that would allow matter
or information to travel from one
location to another almost instantly
well
wormholes are often depicted as
shortcuts through the universe that
would allow objects or information to
travel vast distances almost instantly
uh
however the existence of wormholes is
still pretty theoretical which is true
um
a black hole being an entrance to a
wormhole is a little a bit of a stretch
but I kind of LED it along so that
wasn't really fair
foreign
the
accuracy
of wormholes
evaluate apparently I was trying to type
the accuracy of wormholes in the science
fiction show
Stargate issue one
someone said uh the cool worlds YouTube
channel also found that chat GPT did not
distinguish between gravitational forces
and tidal forces
uh that might be something to to correct
it on then if if I'm not the only one
getting this this uh ambiguity here
to fix generating a stable uh tunnel
through space and time is largely
consistent with the current
understanding of wormholes and physics
which is based on the theory of general
relativity
uh however this this show does not take
some Crea it does take some creative
liberties with the concept of wormholes
and their properties that is that is
true it does do that
uh the Stargate is able to open a
wormhole almost instantly whereas in
reality it is not clear how a wormhole
could be opened or how long it would
take in addition the show depicts uh for
any Galactic travel which is not
possible according to well that's not
true
um there's nothing that there's nothing
that I'm aware of that says that
wormholes can't do Intergalactic travel
um
although they do depict the Wormhole as
a flat circle which it is not a wormhole
would be a sphere you could enter it
from any direction
and you'd be able to see
what was on the other side of it
uh which is kind of cool because light
would actually travel Through the
Wormhole
uh and there's one thing that bothers me
about the show is they have radio
signals radio signals can come go back
and forth both directions uh but
apparently visible light can't
which is silly it's all the same stuff
um as far as a wormhole is concerned
anyway
um
foreign
I cannot type evaluate today evaluate
the accuracy
of artificial gravity
in various
science fiction man
science fiction shows
that's good you know when you've got a
spinny part of your ship that absolutely
works that that does not I mean we can
do that now
um
it's gravitational plating and stuff in
the floor when you start to get out of
out of control a bit
uh see in most cases artificial gravity
is depicted as a technology that
generates a gravitational field within a
confined space
um
whereas greatly depending on the show
uh one of the main challenges in
creating artificial gravity is the fact
that gravity is a very weak force and it
is difficult to generate a gravitational
field that is strong enough to have a
noticeable effect on objects that's true
uh in addition the laws of physics that
govern the behavior of gravity are not
well understood well
that depends on how you look at physics
I'm a little offended
um it is not clear our gravitational
field would be generated or controlled
artificially that that's true
um
what about spinning space stations
oh no
Dave Dave Hensley says uh ask it to
write a song in the style of Bob Dylan
that answers the question any physical
question I wanted to ask
um okay we'll we'll give that a shot
spinning space stations are common
depiction blah blah blah saying it again
uh it would need to be large enough and
spin fast enough to create a noticeable
centrifugal force sure uh while a
centrifugal force is fictitious it does
technically exist within the rotating
frame of reference
so I'll allow it uh the amount of
artificial gravity that a spinning space
station would generate would depend on
size shape and spin rate which is true
how fast
would a one mile diameter
Space Station
need to spin
to generate
Earth's gravity
what
what
happened
I think I broke it
should I refresh
scroll down to the bottom of the
conversation
foreign
there we go
that was close
all right
correctly converted to meters
we need to spin at a rate of about 7.2
revolutions per minute
it did the calculation
not bad not bad and this outlining
exactly how it did it
foreign
you know I'm really glad that I'm not a
classroom teacher anymore
having to adapt my entire
my the entire structure of my class to
account for the existence of these
things I that is a huge overhaul I do
not envy teachers right now going into
the uh winter semester
oh it it said it and we lost it I think
I think it's having issues
it was outlining the whole thing and
then
and then it broke
and it's gone bummer
come on
okay
so uh see I think we're gonna go for
another 10 minutes or so and then I'm
gonna call it but I want to make sure I
get this Bob Dylan question in here
because this is gonna be fun
it changed its answer
huh
oh I changed it to the revolutions per
second
which
I mean 7.24
divided by
60 is not 1.41 so this is this is a
different answer than it gave me last
time
um but I would have to uh
I'd have to double check it this is this
is nice though all right Bob Dylan
question
cloudflare issue yeah so reloaded it
it's fine
uh all right let's see
let's pick out a physics question
can you explain
what the
foreign
due to gravity
is constant
across Earth's surface
but as a song
and the style of Bob Dylan
glad there's a spell check here
foreign
sure here's a short song in the style of
Bob Dylan oh boy
a lot of a lot of people are gonna have
to adapt to this
I mean just because it's giving lyrics
and it's giving lyrics into specific
specific style doesn't mean the song's
any good
oh wow okay
uh
wow I'm just a simple physicist trying
to understand
the mysteries of the universe and the
forces that command wow this is I can I
can hear Bob Dylan's voice in my head as
I read this
this is this is this is impressive
um
see I'm just as simple physicist trying
to understand the mysteries of the
universe and the forces that command
my Bob Dylan impression is horrible but
you're gonna have to live with it
gravity is such a strange force it pulls
us to the ground but why is it constant
all over this round ball we found wow
I am I am impressed right I think this
goes back to uh I think it was uh
acapella science that said this on
Twitter recently
is that like you know we all have
creative jobs you know
um and I think
all us like YouTubers and stuff and I
think that like it's gonna be
we're just gonna have to like make stuff
that AIS can't make
you know there's always going to be
things that you know it can't do or
can't do well
and we just figure out what it is you
know and maybe like
you know we can if this stuff this
technology improves we can like offload
it
offload the more tedious stuff
um and you know I think I think we'll
we'll adapt it'll be okay I'm not too
worried about it
um it is a little freaky but
I'm not I'm not too worried
this isn't the apocalypse or anything
sing
um the last time I sung on my YouTube
channel
it was the most embarrassing thing I
actually put out I don't think it's
public anymore
foreign
but I found I was playing around they
had just
um I think they had just added the uh
the music library for YouTube creators
and
um I decided to just mess around it was
back in my early experimental days on
YouTube and I decided to mess around and
just I wrote a song called Ode to energy
it was so bad I am not I'm not a
musician
um and so
uh maybe one of these days I'll um one
of my one of my friends his name is
Jesse he's he's a musician and he uh he
wrote a song once about conservation of
energy for his classroom he's also a
physics teacher
um and it was really good he came in and
played it on what did he play it on with
the ukulele it might have been a ukulele
but uh
but it can be done right jingle physics
can happen it's just not my skill set
uh let's see uh wootic says uh I had uh
I hadn't make audio by having it write a
python script making each note for Super
Mario
uh like I've seen I've seen people use
this to code like a midi file
um which is just a bunch of like you
know
tower speaker notes like just
frequencies and stuff
um very basic sound file
uh and that's been successful for people
um you might have to tweak the code a
little bit sometimes it likes to add
extra code in that's not necessary
um but yeah it it it it works right it
actually it actually does work as long
as the it's it's it's it's in a simple
thing that it can understand like code
um
it's not going to create the auto file
for you but the audio file for you but
it will do it I have seen it done
let's see
it says chat GPT is bad at math can't
even do proper arithmetic with uh five
digits well that's
but the thing is like you know computers
might be good at math mostly uh until
you get floating Point numbers get weird
um there's weird gaps in the number line
but
um
even though computers generally can do
math well
uh this particular code is this
particular software is designed
it's not designed to do math it's
designed to have a conversation
you know if you're going to do math you
use a calculator use a different tool
this is a tool for a specific purpose
uh and so that's just something to to
keep in mind there so it it might be bad
at math like I said it gave me two
different answers when I asked the
question two different times
um
and so I think we just have to be
careful about
you know what what AI is being trained
on and that things aren't like being
stolen from people
uh which is the problem with a lot of
the AI art that that is going around
these days
um someone said when when can it do my
taxes
uh that'll never happen H R Block will
never let that happen
um you know all those things H R Block
uh Turbo Tax they all they all Lobby the
US government at least at least the US
government for
um to keep taxes complicated so they can
stay in business so taxes will never be
easy it's just it's not a thing
um
uh computer used to be a job now it's a
machine yeah so like that's the thing
that's how our society changes right I
mean we automate a particular task and
then
um we just have to make sure that when
those those people are
well we get two options right we can
either make sure the people that are
losing their jobs are
trained and put into a different job or
call me crazy uh we can just stop
assigning the value of a person to the
job they're doing just you know just a
thought
uh we used to use horses to travel
around and now horses are more of a
a niche thing you know Niche Niche thing
um
there are a lot fewer horses now than
there used to be
uh I would rather that not be the
direction that the human race goes but I
I don't I don't know
um and so this is an ai's fault the the
existence of the AI is not the problem
it's it's our
it's how society looks at people that's
that's the real problem here
um if we looked at people better and we
valued people better I think that these
sorts of changes would not really be
that big of a deal
anyway I think
I'm not getting political I'm getting
sociological but uh
obviously everyone has their own opinion
and that's that's fine but
um I'm allowed to have mine it's it's
you know
uh all right so so that's when it's 3 30
for me it's an hour and a half I think I
think that's a good time to stop
um thank you for the very active chat
this was a really I had a really good
time
um let's uh switch this back
all right
so I had a really good time today this
uh this turned out better I've been
worried about this for a week I wasn't
sure how this was gonna go
um and so I am I'm very pleasantly
surprised you were all very uh
very civil in the comments which you
know my comment section is always
really civil and I I appreciate that
given the uh you know dumpster fire that
the internet can be so um thank you all
for being great
and uh
thank you all for showing up this was a
good time I'm sure we'll do another live
stream at some point this year
um
not like overly like a lot no I've been
doing these once a month or anything but
um definitely again in 2023
but on that note uh I'll see y'all later
have a good rest your day good rest of
your weekend good rest of your night if
uh that's your time zone and uh yeah
thanks